das gab es wirklich noch nie die
japanische regierung hat einem
forschungsteam aus togo jetzt die
erlaubnis gegeben ein mischwesen aus
mensch und tier zu züchten
dazu sollen menschliche stammzellen
embryonen eingesetzt werden doch nicht
nur das diese menschen schimären dürfen
dann erstmalig quasi bis zur geburt
heranreifen
die fachleute wollen somit langfristig
ersatz organe aus vermenschlichten
tieren erzeugen tiere als
ersatzteillager oder organ verbringen
also kritiker sprechen von einem
epischen mega verstoß kriegs und science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nicht sollte übrigens
von dem sommercamp vom frei ds for
future herzlich willkommen und vielen
dank für euren super spannenden themen
vorschlag der über die telefon community
kamen den link dazu gibt es in der video
beschreibung das was die japanische
regierung jetzt nun genehmigt und
finanziert ist wirklich einmalig konkret
geht es über ein experiment des
forschers hiromichi der mischwesen aus
tier und mensch bis zur geburt
heranreifen lassen möchte langfristig
gesehen könnten so schweine erzeugt
werden die als organspender für
menschliche patienten und patientinnen
dienen und somit dem weltweiten
organmangel entgegenwirken auch in
anderen ländern wie den usa wurden
bereits hybrid embryos aus menschen und
tiere gezüchtet auch in deutschland ist
die forschung und züchtung mit schimären
erlaubt das gebären dieser mischwesen
aber ausdrücklich nicht und so haben die
forschungsteams weltweit solche
gezüchtet mischwesen immer frühzeitig
getötet doch das ist diesmal anders hier
um mit sonakshi von der university of
tokyo möchten nicht nur menschliche
zellen in die embryonen schleusen
er möchte sie auch bis zur geburt
heranwachsen lassen eine änderung des
japanischen gesetzes aus dem märz dieses
jahres macht das möglich das japanische
wissenschaftsministerium hatte damals
einschränkungen aufgehoben
die sich auf das einsetzen menschlicher
stammzellen in tieren beziehen
diese neuen regeln erlauben des
forschungsteams in japan tiere zu
züchten die quasi menschliche organe
ausbilden das team ist also das erste
das nicht nur mensch tier schimären
erzeugt sondern diese quasi bis zur
geburt heranwachsen lässt
der japanische forscher will diese
experimente schrittweise durchziehen
in einem ersten schritt sollen
menschliche zellen
ratten und mäuse embryonen eingesetzt
werden 14 halbtage sollen die embryonen
im körper des muttertieres heranwachsen
dann sind sie schon relativ weit
entwickelt gewöhnlich tragen mäuse ihre
jungtiere etwa 20 tage lang ähnlich bei
den ratten hier sollen die mischwesen
embryonen 15 halbtage muttertier
heranwachsen zum vergleich 23 tage
beträgt die gewöhnliche tragedauer der
ratten
auch hier sind die embryonen also schon
relativ weit in ihrer entwicklung dann
sollen nach dem plan von macau sie auch
größere tiere herhalten beispielsweise
schweine
auch hier sollen menschliche zellen in
schweine embryonen eingesetzt werden die
73 tage in einer so heranwachsen
für dieses experiment fehlt dem
japanischen forscher allerdings noch
eine finale genehmigung auf zellebene
soll das ganze so ablaufen den naga
embryos werden sogenannte induzierte
pluripotente stammzellen ips-zellen
eingepflanzt diese entstehen in dem
ausgereifte körperzellen eines
erwachsenen menschen auf einen sehr
frühen embryonalen zustand
zurückprogrammiert werden die biochemie
macht das möglich so können hautzellen
die eigenschaften von embryonalen
entwickeln aus denen sich dann wiederum
quasi jeder zelltyp des menschlichen
körpers entwickeln kann genetisch
gesehen sind solche ips zellen also
identisch mit den ursprünglichen
hautzellen und das bringt einen
entscheidenden pluspunkt mit sich gewebe
das daraus gezüchtet wird würde nach
einer transplantation nicht vom
immunsystem des spenders abgestoßen
werden was hinzukommt kein embryo muss
sterben um solche ips-zellen zu gewinnen
in den experimenten des japanischen
forschungsteams werden die naga embryos
genetisch verändert und zwar so dass
ihnen eine eigene bau speicheldrüse
fehlt so erhoffen sich die fachleute
dass die föten aus den menschlichen
induzierten pluripotenten stammzellen
eine bauchspeicheldrüse entwickeln aber
auch an anderen stellen im körper dieser
mischwesen aus tier und mensch könnten
sich menschliche stammzellen verbreiten
dies könnte das experiment dann auch
zeigen so heißt es vom japanischen
wissenschaftsministerium ein ähnliches
experiment hatte das team um nach aeschi
schon vor zwei jahren 2017 durchgezogen
damals hatten die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler ips zellen von
mäusen in ratten embryos eingepflanzt
die durch eine genetische manipulation
ebenfalls nicht in der lage waren eine
eigene bauchspeicheldrüse zu
wir könnten das experiment wurde als
erfolg versprechen gefeiert denn die
ratten hatten tatsächlich
bauchspeicheldrüsen entwickelt die aus
mäusezellen bestanden und nicht nur das
die so gezüchteten organe wurden dann in
mäuse eingesetzt die an diabetes
erkrankt waren
die tiere waren dadurch tatsächlich in
der lage ihren blutzuckerspiegel wieder
zu regulieren dass ersatz organ hatte
die tiere wieder gesund gemacht wir sind
allerdings noch lange davon entfernt
organspenden aus tieren zu gewinnen denn
das was nach aeschi macht ist reine
grundlagenforschung mäuse und ratten
sind evolutionär weit vom menschen
entfernt und so sind die menschlichen
zellen gar nicht in der lage lange in
den fremden körpern zu überleben zudem
sind die tiere viel zu klein um in ihnen
echte menschen organe zu züchten ähnlich
bei schweinen auch hier besteht eine
große hürde in dieser technik darin dass
mensch und schwein evolutionstechnisch
gesehen relativ weit voneinander
entfernt sind wahrscheinlich werden so
gerade noch jahrzehnte vergehen bis
patienten und patientinnen die
vergeblich auf ein organ warten
mit dieser technik golf werden kann und
wenn überhaupt und das ist auch das was
skeptiker und skeptikerin an dieser
ganzen sache so hart kritisieren
es sind nicht wenige fachleute die daran
zweifeln ob diese technik überhaupt
jemals funktionieren wird vorzuziehen
seien andere wissenschaftliche ansätze
mit dem menschliche organe für
transplantationen bereitgestellt werden
könnten beispielsweise beschäftigen sich
andere wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler damit organen von tieren
so umzugestalten dass sie dann auch
menschen eingesetzt werden könnten
es gibt zudem auch befürchtungen dass
sich solche ips sensor in den tieren
einnisten dass sie sich im schlimmsten
fall zu und samenzellen entwickeln oder
aber dass sie die kognitiven
eigenschaften von den tieren der
verändern dazu
der molekularbiologe jens reich aus
berlin es ist sehr heikel
solche versuche zu machen die gefahr
dabei ist dass man ja sehr potente
menschliche stammzellen in einen
tierischen embryo hinein gibt und man
dann nicht mehr verhindern kann dass die
etwas machen was nicht mehr
kontrollierbar ist zum beispiel dass sie
in dem versuchstiere hirnzellen bilden
und auch andere dinge können in den
anstehenden experimenten noch schief
gehen beispielsweise dass sich
krebszellen entwickeln und dass die
menschlichen zellen zugrunde gehen auch
der spd gesundheitsexperte karl
lauterbach gehört zu den kritikern
in einem spiegel interview sprach er von
einem ethischen mega verstoß seiner
ansicht nach sind die experimente nicht
tragbar mit der züchtung von menschen
mischwesen wird eine grenze
überschritten die wir als menschen nicht
überschreiten dürfen
der deutsche ethikrat hat 2011 eine
stellungnahme zu diesem thema
veröffentlicht die bis heute gilt
ethisch vertretbar sind experimente
demnach wenn die grenze zwischen mensch
und tier klar erkennbar bleibt und
sowohl das tierschutz als auch das
embryonenschutzgesetz streng eingehalten
wird zudem muss auch der nutzen für den
menschen groß seien somit befürwortet
der deutsche ethikrat also tier
experimente mit vermenschlichten tieren
die zu dienen organe in tiere zu züchten
und diese dann auf den menschen zu
übertragen
dazu der sozialethiker petersburg der
vorsitzende des deutschen ethikrates im
interview mit dem nachrichtendienst pd
man denkt vielleicht an pegasus sphinx
kentauren oder irgendwelche horror
monster aus hollywood trashfilm dem sei
nicht so hinter den experimenten stünde
ein hohes ziel in der medizinforschung
geht es übrigens schon seit jahren um
die erzeugung von schimären in
deutschland konzentrieren sich
forschungsdienst vor allem auf die
gentechnische veränderung der tiere
durch die gen scheren namens christa
klaß 9
hierbei werden oberflächen moleküle der
tiere organe so verändert dass sie
menschlichem gewebe ähneln so erhofft
man sich dass nach der transplantation
keine abstoßungsreaktion stattfinden
wir spielen gott gentechnik mit christa
karas 9 hier erkläre ich genau was es
mit der gegenwehr auf sichert also
anklicken anschauen und an alle nicht
abonnenten und abonnenten spätestens
jetzt klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran